hey guys chastity and Tony here we're at
New York comic-con 2019 not currently
but we just came from a demo for
Marvel's Avengers and we got to check
out comic-con aka miss Marvel in a new
demo and she's in the harm room it's a
holographic room where you get to test
out your powers so what do you think of
Cola Kamala was awesome I think I have
found my new main character for this
game
the stretchy powers are super cool she's
got the ability to ambiguous when she
does that she can reach across the room
and slap enemy she's slamming okay
it's so cool it looks like that like
little slappy gel hand toy that you get
she can heal herself through like sheer
willpower yeah I really really enjoyed
playing as comic-con like I said I think
she's gonna be my main for this game and
she is actually literally the main
character of this game as we learned
yeah we found that she's the protagonist
yes she is the hero of this Avengers
game yeah it's comma ylim versus aim so
aim are the enemies and they're very
science driven tell us more about them
so aim advanced idea mechanics
you might recognize the acronym from
Iron Man 3 they're essentially one of
those big tech companies that takes over
and of course anytime a big corporation
is in charge something's not quite right
if it's almost a police state kind of
thing going on comic-con is not a fan of
that so she realizes something's up she
hacks into them she wants to help the
Avengers kind of get back on their feet
after things went wrong so she really is
like the impetus that gets them going
again turns them into heroes again yeah
speaking of other heroes we got to play
through the demo that a lot of people
got to check out at Gamescom but it's
the introductory training level and it's
on the Golden Gate Bridge
once again the Golden Gate Bridge
destroyed always always oh and that is
the incident in fact that like sort of
turns the Avengers off to the world for
a bit yeah so we tried out five
different heroes we've got the main
Avengers here we've got Hulk we've got
Iron Man we got cap we've got Black
Widow we've got Thor who did you like
working with the most I really really
liked playing his Hulk Hulk definitely
smash was a lot of fun he can do like
that thing he did in Avengers where he
just picks up Loki like smacks him on
the ground it's really cool just like
basically using enemies against
themselves he can you know slam down
from the ground he's almost got like
parkour moves where he's like leaping
off of rubble he's ripping the tops off
tanks
even really feel the power of Hulk when
you're playing his Hulk I agree I think
that Hulk was the most satisfying it was
really cool just to like pick people up
and then just like slam them against
someone else's wow this is really good I
also liked playing with door I thought
Thor was super satisfying I liked his
melee attacks and I like that you can
throw me on there and bring it back yeah
it felt a lot like using the Leviathan
axe from God of War so they were both
great I also really enjoyed Black Widow
Black Widow is much more of a grappler
she's also got her guns she can even
turn invisible that's like one of her
yeah that's like one of her ultimate
moves and in fact you have to do that to
finish that demo because you're up
against taskmaster so yeah we got a bit
of a boss fight versus taskmaster I
thought he was interesting like he's
just kind of this dude wearing a mask
yeah he just shows up yeah I mean I will
yeah I will say aesthetically he didn't
necessarily stand out too much that's
kind of a critique that people have
already been leveling at this game is
the character designs don't stand out so
much I'm optimistic that other villains
in the game will be more stylized but
yeah when taskmaster shows up kind of
just a dude in a mask in a hoodie
doesn't stand out to that degree but the
fight itself a lot of fun a good way to
sort of really like make sure you
understand the mechanics of dodging and
grappling and that sort of thing so I
did quite enjoy playing the demo as all
the heroes I thought Ironman was also
fun but I need to get more time cuz like
I feel like I was able to use Thor right
away I was able to use Hulk right away
but I was it was a little trickier with
Ironman I think just with the flight
yeah a lot of the characters are sort of
just beat him up characters but as you
said Ironman can fly so at anytime you
can jump up and hover and yes some of
those flight controls were a little
weird the beginning section where he
plays him it's kind of an on-rails
shooter the handling on that was a
little strange
but it is also worth pointing out that
the demo we played was pre-alpha
so literally anything we say about the
gameplay here can change by the game's
release date but with that said I had a
lot of fun playing with all the
different heroes like even cap to even
just we just got a taste of him but I
liked everything he did with this shield
you'll find one of the six that you
liked playing the most and from there
you'll be able to sort of customize
their moves to which I also thought was
really cool
Shepard
each hero also has skill trees so Iron
Man for example he's got his laser ease
these guys Rockets even as sort of a set
of skills for shields so you can play
offensively or defensively and even
switch between those on the fly so not
only does each here I have their own
unique play style overall but then you
can also sort of hone in on the
particular skills you like the most in
customizing them even more to the way
you like to play so if you like playing
more melee style with Thor you upgrade
that tree if you like throwing the
hammer around more you upgrade that tree
so it just gives you more options to
play these heroes that you already like
and the way that you unlock those is
through missions so let's talk about
missions so we've got the hero missions
and we have the warzone missions so hero
missions are the ones that drive the
story forward and because of that you
play them solo and you are locked to a
particular hero for those you'll play a
mission that is meant for Ironman to
play you'll play one that you can only
use Hawk 4 and those are at like I said
the ones that drive this story forward
but then the warzone missions are more
sort of about expanding the universe so
that's where you'll encounter your side
characters and do like those other side
quests and those you can do with four
players and co-op and you can choose any
four heroes to do for that whether it's
the six that they have it launched
whether it's more they're adding in the
future yes they wouldn't tell us who but
they are working on heroes to add
post-launch
fingers crossed for star-lord he's
always been my favorite Moon Knight also
you're not just stuck in one area the
Helicarrier is the base of operations
and it takes you all over the globe so
you can play those missions all over the
planet yeah it's not like one big open
world necessarily it's more about
choosing specific sort of set-piece
missions the region we saw was I believe
the American Southwest but you can pull
back to the entire United States you can
pull back further from that for like the
globe overall and I imagine you could
probably pull back farther for some more
like interstellar encounters because
marvel's got plenty of that stuff too so
overall what do you think of the demo
now that I've actually been able to play
it I'm much more excited I think they're
kind of running into a bit of a problem
sort of selling the game in terms of
like how it's actually played again it
was pre-alpha but now that we've gotten
a chance to actually see it in action
I'm far more excited for this and
they're gonna talk more about coop and
that sort of stuff in the future and I
think that's much like me that's when
other people are going to be more
bored when they can actually see this
game in action I agree I can't wait to
play more and I can't wait to play with
other people like with my friends and
co-op and see how that goes and you will
be able to play with your friends on ps4
first because that's where the beta is
happening obviously simultaneous launch
later on other platforms but ps4 gets
the beta first that's right and you can
also play it on PC Xbox one and Google
stadia on May 15 2020 and for all things
with near comic-con Marvel and all the
things you love stick with GameSpot
[Music]